hi everyone my name is andre and i'm
product manager of pie charmander spell
at jetbrains uh very excited to be here
thanks for having me um and today gonna
talk about developer tools
uh and in particular about jupiter
notebooks and jetbrains data spell
so what's what's jailbrain's data spell
this is a new id
some of you might have heard of it
already uh some are not and that's uh
that's why i'm very excited
um it um it is a new id uh which
combines uh two
different uh dev other developer tools
such as repeating all books and pycharm
uh into one id which is
built and designed specifically for data
scientists that are involved in
exploratory data analysis and
prototyping ml models
right
data spell was initially announced in
march earlier this year um and as as a
under private uh beater and then we've
invited gradually small groups of people
to try it and share their feedback with
us we've collected a lot of feedback
and
since then every month we keep on
releasing new updates new ep builds
where we try to address uh the feedback
uh they like fix the issues found by the
users and also add what people ask us to
in terms of features
and last months we've uh
we've made the the beat public for
everyone and invited who've been waiting
in line
which is a super great news so now
anyone who is interested in data spell
can can go to the website and without
any registration just download the build
um give it a try and then join the
community also on slack and uh and share
the feedback um
right and um so what the agenda for this
uh presentation like or there'll be two
parts uh first is a little bit maybe
slightly more boring uh it's gonna be uh
talking and i'll i'll gonna tell you the
story behind data spell how we
came to the decision to to build a
separate id why why a new id like how is
it gonna be different and
uh all of that and in the second uh part
of the presentation which i'll try to
make a little a little bit longer than
the first one i'll try uh to stop
talking and
uh we'll show you um data spell in
action and we'll see how it works in
action
right uh so where do i start um
so
yeah uh like it's not a secret for
anyone here in this uh uh conference uh
python is a number one language for data
science and um
um according to one of the latest uh
cargo surveys published i believe last
month
um
um one one out of three data scientists
uh actually use pycharm for
working with python code which is a huge
number and uh at jetbrains we um are
really excited about that that that uh
data science actually use pycharm
uh but what's even more interesting is
that uh the same um cargo survey
actually tells that while pycharm is
used by one out of three data scientists
um
am another tool so like also vs code and
other ids
um
same same data scientists actually use
uh jupiter notebooks as uh twice more
often
basically two out of three data
scientists uh actually use uh jupiter
notebooks
and
um our over like recent years are the
users of pycharm uh asked us uh
for quite a long time to add support for
jupiter notebooks in in in pycharm and
following that all all that requests
we've actually
done that uh some time ago a long time
ago actually and what has changed since
then like on one hand we've received a
lot of complaints from data scientists
who actually are in love with jupiter
notebooks uh
reaching out to us and telling that the
existing support in in python for
jupyter notebooks is inadequately not
enough and they asked for a lot more um
and um
secondly of course now we see in the
statistics that the adoption of jupyter
notebooks has only grown
and uh that made us um um
start to think about it more seriously
and a year
and a half um
ago our team said together uh and and
decided to rethink our approach to
providing uh data science uh tools
within pycharm and id in general
um and uh what we came to like in terms
of our decision and how we're going to
do that like
um i mean it took quite a lot of efforts
to realize and it was shocking to to
realize how different the workflow
between data scientists and developers
and um when you come out of data science
background it's not shocking for you
it's quite obvious like you even
appreciate uh some some of the practices
that uh uh developers have and you try
to integrate them into your data science
workflow however if you come from uh
development and you start see how data
science actually do what they do
it it might be very shocking and it
might take a significant um effort from
you to get used to this uh to the ways
and um pycharm has always been designed
as an idea for developers in mind and
all the workflows are optimized for
development so it took us for quite a
while to try to look at this from a
different angle that's that's how data
spell was born and we decided to focus
uh on the interactivity
uh which is uh very important we believe
for data science so if you come to think
like what is the difference between data
scientists and developers when you
when you
a developer and when you write your code
most of the time you read your code and
you write your code and then you also
run your application and then you can
work with the application but what
happens with when you do data science uh
you have to explore data and you have
prototype your models you actually work
with the data and not with code so much
and uh how do you work with with data
you you run curious you see the output
you work with output data like bit
tables or data frames or
visualizations uh so interactivity is
the key and that's uh that's one main
principle for for us now on to
focus uh when we come up with developer
tools for data sciences and the second
one is of course distinguishing their
workflows between data science and
developers and trying not to mix them
together
um so that's that's how data spells
started and um
even though data spell is not released
yet um it's it's already used by
thousands of data scientists we have
active slack channel where people come
and share
their feedback about the product and try
to listen to to that feedback and um um
with every release we try to make it
even better all right hi
sir sir to interact are you showing your
id
i
showing the id because we can still see
the slide
um thanks uh that's exactly the moment
when i stop uh showing that slide and
start showing the id uh
thanks um so here we go um uh
probably uh it's even better to to see
in an action um
rather than here many times about it uh
here we go um
here's the toolbox app uh which
well anyone can use to to work with
jetbrains id we have quite quite uh
quite many here and now here's a new
element which is item which is called
data spell that's exactly the idea i
want to show you today um
so when you launch it the first time
what you'll notice uh the first the
first time you do that is the welcome
screen uh typically it appears only once
and uh what it what is what it is for is
helping you set up your environment
um and if you for example have your
conda uh installed locally to detect it
right away if you if you wanna change it
to some other uh environment you can
also choose between bayes environment
and
other continuing environments and of
course you can use virtualenv and
other
other
types of interpreters
so if you using the baseconda you don't
really have to do anything you just
click launch and then the id
opens
and
that's how they are the data spell id
looks like um what you may notice is um
it looks pretty similar to pycharm in a
way of course if you uh tried pycharm
before um we have two windows we have
main menu we have main toolbar and uh
the editor area uh what is different um
is
there um
is that um while pycharm offers you to
work with individual projects uh data
spell by default um
like
prompts you to to work with their
workspaces where you can attach multiple
projects and work with them and switch
between between them
as you'd like to
and
basically you can
attach local folders and work with the
files
and also can connect a data spell to
remote
jupyter notebook servers so how do you
do that so here instead of like in
pycharm you have a project tool window
we have a workspace tool window and here
we can use these buttons to either
attach local folders
or
connect
the id to a remote instance of jupyter
notebook server or jupyter hub or
jupyter lab for that matter all you need
to do is to paste the url here and then
um if the remote server you use a
certain type of authentication like
password token um it will prompt you to
enter it and then it will attach the
content of the remote
server here and you'll be able to see
the files browse them and open them edit
and run them uh for for this particular
demo
we're going to use the the local
project which i've prepared uh but
please expect that uh
both remote and uh local
um
environments uh work pretty much similar
way
um right so uh in this demo i'm going to
to open this titanic sample project
from kaggle uh
and it's it's very simple one but it
allows us to to to see a data spell in
action so what what what we have here is
um some some data a csv file um a simple
python script and a notebook so
let's let's start with data
right when we open a csv file we
actually are able to see it as a table
it detects headers we can
interactively work with the data and
sort it and um
filter as as we want and if we need we
also can switch to to the raw format and
uh work with it from here however right
now we are not interested in working
with raw data using like this um
user interface but actually interested
in uh notebooks so let's
go straight ahead and open a notebook
from this sample project
right
um
so
yeah let me open it um so when you open
an old book in data spell what you
notice is that notebooks
actually look a pretty similar way as
you expect them to look when you open
them in a browser
uh
what's interesting here is that um the
the comment mode actually works as
exactly as uh in the wrap based uh
notebooks so you can use the arrow keys
to navigate uh quickly over the cells
you can switch
from the common mode to the editor mode
for example and if this is a markdown
uh cell you'll be able to see the syntax
highlighting and all that um uh it
supports all their uh standard markdown
um format and of course it supports also
the latex expression which is good this
is a new feature we just added it in the
last build which we released yesterday
and when you run the cell it basically
renders the markdown um
nicely uh right in place and
same way you can
switch to the editor mode for the editor
editors like code cells and um in the
cells you can expect all the coding
assistance uh that you would normally
have for python scripts and pycharm so
let's just
quickly see what we can do here so it
provides code completion
uh for the variables and also um now
transistory then we also use may use
some
basic refactorings and when we um run
the cell
it shows the the output right below the
cell right in line
which might be great and uh in case this
is a data frame it allows us to
interactively
um
work with this uh
preview of a data frame um and we can
scroll we can sort uh it's by columns
and um uh if if we'd like to
uh work with it more conveniently we can
also click this open a new tab and then
it opens as a separate uh editor and
then we can uh continue working with the
data frame
in a more convenient manner so when when
we are done we just close it and get
back to our notebook
and um
when for example we run a cell which
produces
a chart well you can expect that it
supports uh different type different
libraries for visualization and outputs
uh
well charts uh it supports matlab leap
and plotly and vocab
um
so here's the static um
or out static uh plots but but it also
supports mostly bokeh altered and other
javascript based um
charts including um
um
notebook widgets
right
um so what what's what else is
interesting of course uh if if you uh
click on the left hand side of uh code
cell you'll be able to put a breakpoint
and then uh if you run a cell the cell
in a in a
debug mode
of course it will stop at the breakpoint
and you'll be able to step over the code
or step into the code and uh if you're
using your uh some some of your
functions from other modules you'll be
able to step in or same for uh libraries
that you use
and um as you step over the code uh you
can see the current state of the
variables and you can also for example
enter arbitrary expressions uh
um
and uh
sorry
when you
evaluate these expressions you you'll be
able to see the result and then if you
click for example here it will open the
the data frame which is an output of
your uh expression which you've typed
here and you you'll be able to to to
work with it as a with the as a
table uh basically right
um um so what else uh as an alternative
to the debugger um sometimes you might
want to um
uh evolate certain expression
without uh using uh without printing
this uh in into the output of the cell
so uh
you can do that uh by using this uh
jupiter console this is also a new
feature which we read just uh in the in
the last update so basically we've just
connected to the currently opened um
kernel
uh
with uh can console um
and and then you can in this console you
can um
evaluate type any expressions and see
the outputs it supports plots and
um data frames and this might be a good
uh option um
as to
when when you need to evaluate something
really quickly
right um so
lastly
if you have
headers in your markdown
in your notebook you can also open the
structure tool window which
detects the all the headers that you use
in markdown and let you navigate over
them with one click which is also might
be quite helpful so if you typically
work for example with jupiter lab
please do expect to have all the
features of jupiter lab here provided by
the id and probably even more
um i think that uh that's the
uh the notebooks
um and how about
python scripts uh let us
open a python script here right so
what we see here is um typical
editor of the id
um
we also see that the id detects the this
uh notation when we split the parts of
your scripts into separate cells which
makes it possible to run different cells
and treat them as
quite close to how jupiter notebooks
treat cells right
we also have um a toolbar here and this
is another difference between pycharm
and uh data spell that
um
the scripting experience of data spell
is tuned stored uh interactivity and by
default when you run any any part of the
script it runs it in a interactive
scientific mode
um
so let's uh let's just run uh this first
cell and then see how it works
as you see uh it run it in this console
and we see the the console right here
and we can either continue running other
parts of that script or we can also
evaluate certain expression here
now if we
run this second cell
what we'll see is that uh the output
appears in the in the console and we
see pretty much same functionality which
is provided with jupyter notebooks what
is also interesting here is that you
don't actually have to use all these
print l print uh statements to
to output the data even even if you are
not in notebook uh and you are in the
python script you can
for example put certain
um at the
end of that
virtual cell
and it will treat it uh as in notebooks
it will output the the thing in in the
console so now if we
uh for example run another cell which
produces uh
two plots it will work pretty much the
same way as uh entropy and notebooks so
basically
uh the script the script you that the
user experience for python scripts
replicates all the functionality which
which is provided by jupiter notebooks
and if uh if you find for example
scripts uh a bit more convenient
uh then then it's a way to go uh and you
can do pretty much anything that jupiter
notebooks allows you to do
right
um
and um it's worth of course mentioning
that
you can use the debugger and it will um
stop at the breakpoints but also what is
interesting is that you can not only run
the whole script at once and or run
individual cells but you can actually
run code line by lines for example
here's an action which allows you to run
uh your code one line by line and then
it um
basically shows the the output in the
console which might be
quite handy sometimes when when you to
really uh kind of
like debug your code without using
debugger in a more interactive fashion
and especially if you for example come
from our studio background and if you
are used to
r studio you might find this familiar
because in our studio that's uh that's
also used pretty much often
right
um
that that is it of course not not uh
uh it's also worth to say that still uh
you are able to run the entire script
and you can even run that script with
additional parameters so if you for
example have certain scripts that
for example acquires or processes data
or do some other does some other
uh batch job uh you'll be able to
to make this configuration and run it uh
when you need it
um right so that's that's mostly it
about the python scripts and
um
lastly um we've now mentioned rstudio um
data spell actually supports not only
python but also supports r
and if you have our installed on your
machine uh data spell it will it will
detect it uh automatically and you'll be
able to create our scripts and
edit them all with all that coding
resistance and
um and it's provided not just for our
script but also for our markdown so it's
where the the experience replicates some
of the experience of jupiter notebooks
so it might be good option um if you
primarily use python but also sometimes
need to work with some r project so if
you use data spell then
sorry then you can use one tool and have
pretty similar experience for both r and
python um right
um
so uh
having said that i just uh would like to
recap some of the most uh important
points um from from this presentation so
number one
uh data spell is a new id uh which
combines the functionality of jupiter
notebooks and pycharm and it takes the
uh the best parts of it and tailors into
their um
and it makes tailored experience uh
specifically for data scientists um
[Music]
it supports local environments and
remote environments
and um the support for local
environments is also going to be
available with pycharm which actually
makes it possible to have a choice
between pycharm and data spell and how
do you how do you choose what would you
use
so a rule of thumb is the following if
your primary if your primary
activities are development software
development
then um then pycharm is the way to go
and in those moments when you need uh to
do some data exploration or prototype
some ml model then you'll be able to
rely on the built-in functionality which
is the same between data spa and pycharm
and if your primary activity is data
science and all you do is exploring data
and then
prototyping ml models then data spell is
the best tool and of course in those
moments when you are um equally involved
in both or then you have a choice
between
both tools and you you can use pycharm
for software development and
data spell for for data science
some
the other thing is
data spell is not released yet but the
ep is public and anybody can go and
download it uh the eep is free to use or
data spell is planned as a commercial
ide with pretty same license model as a
python professional and
we plan to release it also
as long as the feedback continues to be
great and we are
we welcome you to to give a try to data
spell uh now that it's an eap forum and
share your feedback with us
um
and that's uh mostly it so we still have
three minutes and i'll be very happy to
to look at some of the questions if we
have them
let me stop sharing the screen and um
see the the q a session
um
right so the first question happy happy
python professional user here why didn't
you just improve the pie chart notebook
experience um i asked him the the
question is like uh why instead of
making a separate uh id
um
not just uh work on their notebook
support in python so there are several
reasons like number one nobody stops us
from improving their notebook support in
pycharm which is exactly what we've done
and uh with the release with the
upcoming release of pycharm the notebook
support in patch are going to be um
um exactly same as what uh
data spell offers uh however still we'd
like to work towards um
um
we would like to in addition to
making data science experience great in
python we'd like also to focus on those
folks that are less that have less of a
developer background
and we'd like to improve the overall
workflow
by offering a much simpler tool which is
uh more interactive than than pycharm
and that's the ambitious goal we have
and
we do rely on feedback so
think that data science intersects a lot
with development uh however still there
are
a big part of the community which is not
really involved in software development
but involved a lot in uh data analysis
or ex
data exploring exploration or simply in
prototyping models and not so much into
productizing models so
we really want not just improve the data
science experience with our development
tool but also see what how far we can go
with offering a data science purely tool
and um
looking forward to your thoughts on it
as well and in case you for example
don't don't see a sense in it i would be
very happy to to to discuss
um so i i see that we have very little
time um
maybe just uh last question let me
randomly pick up the the last question
um
is there a beam plugin for as for patch
arm yes the bim plugin is there uh there
might be some some some uh still bucks
uh remaining but we work towards fixing
all of them by the release date and vim
plugin will be working there as well
right so
um apologize that i cannot answer all
the questions i would be very happy to
chat in in slack so let's just move all
the questions to the slack channel and
discuss them there
thanks everyone thank you for for your
attention for your time i wish you
a great day hat and take care
you